and i want to encourage two people to
like don't do a press release on your
schedule that's right before you've like
actually done it or you had like
a huge pet be like don't declare it
a lot of big things are coming on the
channel like i have new videos coming
out soon
soon in the next two years
one of my favorite sessions from our
recent grow with video live conference
was a time where we got to sit down with
tony omar and sean and go over what
things are underrated and overrated on
youtube we're going to be bringing that
session to you today and i want to
welcome you to the think media podcast
the number one podcast to help you grow
your influence on youtube and then turn
that influence into a high profit and a
high impact online business thank you so
much for being here if you're new here i
want to encourage you to subscribe to
the podcast wherever you're consuming
this content we post brand new episodes
every single tuesday so make sure you're
subscribed on youtube or apple or
spotify or wherever you like to listen
to this type of content well we're going
to get into today's session where we're
bringing you kind of an unfiltered
version of the think media team you get
to learn a little more about omar and
tony and sean and really our takes on
certain events and certain things and
features about youtube and i threw in a
couple things like their favorite cereal
and other funny things so sit back relax
and enjoy today's episode of the think
media podcast
[Music]
heather torres here i'm with the guys
i'm so excited i'm with omar tony and
sean and we're actually heading into a
very fun segment i've been looking
forward to this one for the entire
conference we're heading into what we're
calling the think battle royale thank
you my husband's calling me right now
while i'm on camera that's right uh i
love you too honey um so we're gonna
play the think battle royale here's how
you play here's how you play okay uh
there's no points this is an open
discussion to your own opinion so take
off your think hat i don't get points
for my opinion no you don't get points
for your opinion nope nope so uh you can
take off your think hat you don't have
to answer like think okay so you can
just give a straight answer which you
normally would do anyways but i'm just
letting you know
um and i'm gonna be giving you some
different um categories and then some
will be related to youtube and some will
not so we will get into it uh and we
will start with first
youtube cards are dead
what do you think tony
youtube cards i think and you're
referring to the cards that are on top
at that you go hey let's click the card
i'm gonna say that youtube cards are
dead i think they're dead they kill your
your attention they pull the viewer out
of the video and it also i don't know if
anybody else has this experience on
youtube i find them really annoying like
i'm watching a video and it like covers
so much of the screen real estate when
you're on a phone i think they're
completely dead stop using cards that's
what i'm gonna say ooh but what do you
do with videos that you already have
cards on
sean
yeah i mean i probably wouldn't go back
and change or fix those um i think that
they're maybe on life support i don't
know if they're actually dead
um like so i do i do these uh like uh
yoga stretching videos for my arms and
my hands and for carpal tunnel and uh
there's this one girl that i watch and
she goes you know hey if you actually
want to do my shoulder thing i did a
video about that you know i'll link it
but here's what she said she's like i'll
link it
i'll put a link to it in the description
if you want to check that out or the
card
that doesn't bother me that she says
that and that education is important and
actually
after the video ends i'm like i do want
to watch that next like in a practical
educating utilitarian way i think that
that is uh something to use and if you
do use them so you don't kill a
retention you could use them towards the
end
maybe before the end card because
there's you still might be landing the
plane for a while
so your videos maybe
i think when it no i think it all comes
back to like do you click
end cards so like sean does click on i
personally
haven't have not clicked an end card i
haven't been convinced enough to like
leave the video like chosen you've never
clicked on it okay that was a false
statement
here's the deal though like here's the
deal though you said you would go back
at the end of the video and click on the
cards for the video right is that what
you're saying like not like i'm saying
30 seconds left and so and your end
screen is in the last 20 seconds and you
know what the call to action would be
you could still put whatever that end
screen
here's the thing that kills the whole
thing
is as i think this year i grow video we
want you you want to look at the data
and when you go into the data and you
actually look at percentagely how many
people take action on cards
seven is high
and a lot of times it's like less than
one percent so what happens is people
focus too much on these small things and
do they matter that much they really
don't for sure and they're either dead
or barely on life support yeah and i
think yeah again i just think most
people when they when they put them they
don't put them right like at the
beginning of the video they will go oh
hey i have another video on this
actually you can click the cart it's
just like you literally just set your
video up to be tanked in the first 20
seconds to like divide the audience even
if it's a little percent i think it
still kills the video all right great
job
what do you think let us know in the
comments do you use cards do you think
they are i like overrated underrated we
can go that way um what about
youtube shorts
youtube shorts are underrated underrated
for sure um we're about we're talking
about them this afternoon and they're
the
supply
is not meeting demand
now if you're in business you got to
really think about that statement if
there is more demand than there is
supply which there is right now the
amount of people that want to consume
shorts is massive it's like 105 billion
views a month there's more shorts views
than views of regular videos right now
now that doesn't mean there's not
without problems the quality of the
viewership the audience the demographic
but i think it would be irresponsible to
ignore youtube shorts i agree with you
uh the only thing i would say that's
overrated about shorts in my mind like
people really put too much value in the
on views on shorts i i don't think
shorts views are the same as youtube
views like youtube shorts when you're
scrolling through something really quick
it's like i mean it's almost like a very
surface level first touch point which i
think shorts are good for but people
sometimes go i got a hundred thousand
views on shorts or like even on tick
tock hundred thousand views and it's
like they didn't really translate to
anything though like even though it's
just a metric it's kind of like you're
saying earlier it did it translated to
vanity okay i know come on that's what
i'm saying but you were saying earlier
that like you know you can't cash in
100k silver play button i feel that same
way about views when it comes to shorts
sometimes and tick tock if you don't do
it smart like if you don't you've got to
have a you got to have a way where where
should they go next or what is even the
purpose of doing them you know like
where are they going to go deeper um
because yeah you get a short that pops
off and
then what you know so where does it go
from there yeah i i mean as someone who
like really enjoys creating quality
content i am biased at this whole short
form uh content revolution me too
it's just like people doing a dance and
getting a million views and you're
life-changing i guess your life changes
with a million views but like are you
monetizing that dance or something like
i mean i i get it i think it's
understanding the the intention we talk
about reverse engineering shorts should
be i would i would i would say that it
should be your intent to to to be seen
and then that's why hopefully having
something that connects them to
something deeper but i think i think at
the end of the day i follow youtubers
that know what they're doing and and i
love their content because of what
they're doing one one that comes to mind
is random golf club uh this guy this guy
makes incredible films around playing
golf and they're just done at such a
high level i would hate for him to drop
shorts but i love but but every time he
drops a video and they're 30 minutes
long i'm on so you get to determine that
but like sean said supply and demand
we're throwing up shorts on
well yeah i think it also depends like
how much energy you're putting like
you're at i for me i think if you're
doing it at the sacrifice of your vray
video yeah i don't think that's worth it
in my mind dude sean i think hashtag
tony the wise
good yeah i mean if it's stealing from
your most significant impact then it
would be not a good use of your time for
me shorts is like another thing to do
like that's what it feels like and it's
like yeah if you are steering away from
the main thing not being the main thing
anymore then it just becomes too much
and we're implementing shorts now with
team and actually most people that we
see that are being successful with
shorts have some type of team built
around them or some type of system built
around them to make that even possible
without burnout without burning out or
it's a viral prank but then again that
those views don't really those aren't
valuable views yeah like the ones i'm
watching are unvaluable to my life at
all they're just funny and the
entertainment stuff but i'm not clicking
follow i'm lit i'm literally just
swiping yeah you know and it's not
actually making me have an it's not
giving me an impact in my life so yeah i
think it's a good we're going deep by
the way you know stick around all day
because i have a full 19 points on
shorts this afternoon yeah so that's
coming up and it's going to be in 20
minutes
19.
exact number of points
on short okay
here's a battle royale question how long
should a video be
i
as long as short as possible as long as
necessary is like the easy cop-out
answer i'm a fan of five to eight
minutes right now yeah
five to eight minutes i would say the
same way i think length really matters
but pacing even matters more i think
like one of the things i always think
about as i will show one of my i have to
probably drive my wife crazy with us but
i literally will show her videos and
films that i'm working on and that's
will be my litmus test when i'm when
she's watching it and then i'm like i
feel cringe or i feel a little like oh
like this is the part's boring this
part's this yeah that's how i know the
video is too long that's where i know if
somebody's watching something and
they're like okay okay and then and then
if it gets dull and they go do they
check in yeah yeah as soon as you lose
them or when you're telling them a story
and it's just disrespectful but
i guess i need to work on my story
telling your stories
sorry
got to be a good storyteller and no i
think that's the thing like omar said
when the person he's invested with the
the golfer you were invested in his
content he drops 30 minutes you're into
it there's a podcaster i listen to her
podcasts are two hours long i listened
to the whole thing while i'm getting
ready
um through i was listening to it's uh
lisa brevier so a lot of their content
wouldn't you have pre-existing trust
with her i did yeah i read her books
not a lot of two-hour things you're
gonna watch from a stranger that's not
recommended to you no no for sure
definitely i mean i get if a video is
five minutes and i'm like i could have
got that in three i don't click on that
person again
because i'm like you are wasting my time
i think when you're starting you should
start with short content and we talk
about speed dating and it's that the
reason you go on speed dates is so you
don't get trapped on a friday night out
with somebody where all of a sudden
they're like let's get gelato first
we'll walk in the park then we're gonna
watch the lord of the rings extended
version and i've got dessert planned
after and you're like wait a minute i
just discovered i don't like your
personality to start with so so speed
dating first and so if you challenge
yourself to make three four five to
eight minute videos that are really
valuable because once you have trust
like sometimes maybe somebody sees
one of our videos of 1.4 million views
i'm teaching for 45 minutes crazy but
yeah i've been working at this for 10
years i've built some trust built up to
that yeah i think you should start with
shorter videos all right i'm gonna throw
some rapid fire overrated underraters at
you guys you tell me what you think
casey neistat
properly rated properly yeah i'd say
properly rated yeah they did
overrated
overrated like now or like yeah i mean
he's he's a le he's if there was a hall
of fame yeah of influence he's
incredible and vlogging especially
he paved the way yeah this is just it is
it is a good lesson on you can't be
number one forever yeah but he had his
well he doesn't have to make money and
he's still casey neistat he's still he's
still casey neistat now when one drops
it blows up because it's rare that it
happens it's like that adele effect yeah
adele doesn't put out albums for like
three four five years on end and when
they drop it's it's instant classic
because we're waiting kendrick mark ii
drop your album yeah you can't say
number one forever unless you're kanye
right just kanye's number one okay all
right ready faceless channels
underrated underrated
super underrated i think more people
should get started
uh with faceless because you don't need
a camera um if you had editing software
if you had the ability to record your
audio on your smartphone and you just
don't want to get ready and you want to
start producing content you might be
able to move quicker i think i think
also it's just the idea like you know
what facebook channels remind me of as
they remind me of niche amazon affiliate
sites they remind me of understanding
that there is an audience there is a
desire for content um there are people
that want to watch something and you
build a business around it so a niche
amazon affiliate site was like all
things pets and dogs and you'd you would
just like eventually link to tons of dog
products so you can make an a faceless
dog channel that's more you're business
minded you're like i like dogs i could
get clips i could get memes off tik tok
i could get a lot of dog stuff and so i
sometimes think that we put too much of
the personal brand on a pedestal
and that faceless channels could be a
huge opportunity that people could
explore i think to i would agree that
overall they're underrated i think that
some people though think they're easy
like they think like like i feel like
for us sitting here knowing positioning
knowing video editing knowing how to
like lead people or if we want to death
with a team and outsource those things i
think if someone's just starting doesn't
know video editing doesn't know that
stuff doesn't understand pacing doesn't
understand positioning it actually could
be a huge mountain for them to climb i i
mean just as hard equally not any
there's no advantage necessarily over
the personal brand they get over hyped
in their simplicity a lot of people are
easy oh it's like it's cash cow they
call it this cash cow channel like turn
this around favorite thing like i'm like
cash
talking to somebody that that spent
twenty thousand dollars on a guru and
spent another three thousand dollars on
promotion and spends 900 a month to keep
the thing running and the channel's
making 80 bucks right now and it was
promised that it'd make a lot more
i'm into them but i don't think nothing
is easy right exactly i don't think it's
that thing worth having come season
yeah
oh okay here is a uh captain crunch
underrated overrated man you eat that
stuff it rips the roof of your mouth up
like razor blades overrated i think
cereal is overrated i'm sorry i would
say so i agree
there's nothing nutritious
like god did not mean cereal for
breakfast
it's not even food my thing is the
nostalgic it's it's nostalgia
nostalgia is not food but man you cannot
live on nostalgia alone omar i do
i stay relishing in my past and i know
i'm going to get some haterade but you
should be eating some like spinach and
some green juice and like some real
chicken that's like not intermittent
fasting don't have breakfast eat your
first meal at 12. that's always an
option intermittent fasting that's why
that's why cereal would be overrated
my mom only allowed me to have kicks
because the first ingredient wasn't the
sugar
corn syrup
we're learning so much about you guys
netflix
overrated or under underrated overrated
no
i think they're overrated i think
there's two there's so much competition
i feel like people like so like oh
netflix netflix but what's happening is
netflix is actually losing a lot of
their ip because these independent
streaming platforms are happening so are
they losing their users they how's their
stock price soon you know what honestly
i'm just talking about from a user
standpoint i'm not talking about i don't
really care about that
he's like he's like oh you could
optimize this even better i think it is
personally i'm like there's nothing to
watch no but they lost freaking the
office they they're losing all these ips
and it's making it
way over it yeah it is literally it is
and they're overrated now we gotta have
peacock for the office you gotta have
like all these things i have so many
subscriptions let me know do you have
like a billion every subscription every
time sean inside of amazon will show up
meeting he's like guys i watch this show
what is it he's like it's on this other
discovery plus
oh yeah like three weeks ago i signed up
it was free for a month but now i'm
locked in apple tv plus espn plus this
is all the pluses yeah okay here's this
one uh
overrated gear overrated or
underweighted rated gear like camera
camera gear
overrated
i would i would agree it's overrated
like
use a window
prop your phone
like
make a video i think gear is properly
rated oh properly okay i think it's
properly rated i think it matters
it doesn't matter as much as you think
it does but you don't also want to
disrespect the gear and i'm excited
because omar is going to be focusing so
much on like smartphone because like
smartphone is and a smartphone is
expensive yeah a good smartphone people
are making that purchase almost every
year or doing like and it's yeah and so
it's smart to get a good smartphone if
you're going to use it for that purpose
or to get two smartphones use your last
year for fully for a camera or whatever
and uh and then to get the gear
necessary for it but yeah it's
definitely over hyped that you need you
know something people are overspending
on gear when they could be i think you
need to spend on gear we studied in that
first session that the average content
entrepreneur is spending ten thousand
dollars to get their career started on
gear and coaching and information
but where you put that some people just
completely spent it all on the camera
when lenses
lighting um lighting audio audio
software
a video editing computer yeah yeah and i
think about gear a lot as
like almost like a painter they're paint
brushes right it's like they still have
to know how to paint like i almost feel
like you need to invest in learning how
to paint learning how to make a good
video before you like invest in a ton of
gear but as leonardo da vinci said yeah
okay oh he said this is amazing i don't
know that's incredible
but he probably he probably uh he
probably probably he probably cared
about his brushes yeah so like you yeah
they are you
they are important dude and i just but i
can't wait for the battle station series
for the new battle station we built with
kyle
and i mean those tools the details
matter like we really i really care like
it's i feel like i am
luke skywalker in an x-wing but you know
how to paint that's what i'm saying he's
like you know what i paint so those
purchases actually like upgrade you
significantly you drop that full battle
station on someone who doesn't know
what's going on and you know yeah and
you know you see you never it's not
about your resources it's about your
reason
and and and from being faithful in the
season when i had the canon hv30 and
when eventually i scrimped to get the
canon 7d not 70d 7d back in 2009 and 10.
in every season i learned how to paint
now you give me a brush
and you get a masterpiece strokes come
on
wow okay all right this is how we make
up i know
yeah sean alluded to like one when when
when kyle built out his washington setup
this is the first time sean was now live
streaming with two angles and he was
able to just to do it naturally it was
like natural with him i think back to it
i think you just got to know where
you're at and and know what you want
yeah so like you know
a lot of times people you know ask me
they want everything but like is it
really just a shot that you need because
it probably is just like a simple setup
that's why i think gear a lot of times
when we get i get i get in arguments
with kyle because i'm like dude we got
it we're good
and he's like no bro we need
a 2 000 slider
no we need the slider or what did i call
it i called it the glider the glider i
was like oh the cool glide the glider
they don't make our life they were so
mad at me listen to michael listen to
michael he said just because you can
drive a car doesn't mean you can fly a
plane
that's it
cool yes savage that's a good one all
right how about this one uh tags
youtube tags
underrated nobody's using them properly
still i think they're overrated youtube
has come out and said that they're not
really a big deal um i think they're a
big deal when you're starting out to
give you clarity on the keywords you're
going for so but i think overall they're
probably overrated right now
i say underrated just because like i
think if you don't know how those work
yeah okay yeah i don't like like people
are still post like posting if they have
a video or they're showing you how to
cook a vegan meal they're like food
network
eat
like yeah you don't get it yet omar i
agree with delmar
i think they're
misunderstood yeah that's right
because
they're overrated to the person who
thinks they're magical keyword things
the fairy dust that are gonna grow their
video but if you don't understand how to
think
if you don't understand how to think and
you're typing food in your tags you
weren't even making the right video
because it should be
best
method for cooking falafels
with organic ingredients that should
literally be the tag phrase the keyword
phrase because you put that much thought
into building your video next one that's
awesome hey if we i want to hear uh some
from the audience so if you've got one
that you'd like to ask us
overrated or underrated there's code
outrage
we have code
outrage right now code outrage right now
okay
okay
oh here's one in the comments uh what is
your hot take on gary garyvee he's one
of our headline speakers for growth
video live 2022.
garyvee is underrated okay why i mean i
think that on the one hand garyvee uh
for people that have followed him for a
while they might be like oh you know
i've heard him he says a lot of the same
inspirational stuff and whatnot but i
think what people don't understand
is the depth and real experience his
entrepreneur wisdom comes from there's a
lot of people that uh just spew hype but
with an 1 000 person company that helps
people with social media social video
with having built and sold mult multiple
different companies and with being you
know the new york times best when you
see the execution
of what he's done as an entrepreneur and
really the practical wisdom and i think
why i'm so excited about having gary vee
at 20 growth video live 2022 is he so
has his finger on the pulse of the now
yeah well what am i going to learn from
him you know today no
he will be coming in with fresh
inspiration that happened that week from
his companies from the front lines from
the campaign they just run from the
social video they were doing so he's
just a real one that's in the trenches
um and then of course you know i've got
a major affinity for him just because of
his impact on our company and my
personal life so yeah i still i think i
think he's underrated and i'm so
grateful that he's speaking at our
conference next year
no yeah i think it's i'm i find it crazy
that like oftentimes you know you'll
meet somebody who's
starting the journey of posting content
or the social media journey mixed in
with their business and like there is
like this assumption that you know who
gary vee is and that
nobody still knows gravy there's still a
lot of people that don't know who he is
and he's he's not giving up you know and
and if there is so much power in saying
the same thing if you think he's saying
the same thing he's doing his job
because you know we we always talk like
it's it's actually when you get sick of
it is when it's actually resonating and
so i i i i commend his position and and
the stance he's taking in culture
uh more than anything else and no dude
it's crazy that he's coming i got a
couple rapid fire from the audience here
and i want to hit i'll ask one person uh
for one person one answer is b-roll
overrated or underrated omar it's
underrated not completely under
make b-roll happen yeah literally and
that's going to boost audience attention
later too as well all right how about
asking people to subscribe or like the
video heather
i think it's underrated because um
because people need to know what to do
next when they think about maybe
different demographics and age groups
they actually need to like know that
that's how they see more videos a lot of
people are on youtube but actually don't
know how to use this i think
demographics come into play that's the
demographics yeah yeah but i feel like
if you
if but depending on your demographic i'm
speaking to
what where yeah maybe the older younger
i think you go gen z and i think they
yeah i think you literally again grenade
especially in the front it's like oh hey
welcome hey i'm you know i'm tony also
can you subscribe and then can you like
and then also don't forget to leave a
comment like i've seen make sure you
keep your like no notable no
notification
bell like and it's like a whole like 40
second it's just whitening yeah it
becomes robotic yeah like i just think
oh like people just starting out i don't
think they have to worry about that sure
there's a ton of energy on it and it
doesn't influence me and i'm not
representative of every people yeah like
well we're saying quality of the content
once i see
like even if i hear it i'm like well i'm
not gonna subscribe because you told me
to i'm gonna see what i'm experiencing
on the channel and if they don't say
anything i'm like dude i'm vibing with
this video you know what i actually love
where they when people place it i love
when people place it at the end of their
video that's the place yeah i think
because not at the beginning if you even
make it there yeah then that's the time
you've built that relationship and it's
after the value yeah yeah this video was
helpful i feel that subscribe uh i would
say in my world i feel like it's
properly rated in the sense that you
know it takes a moment to say
you know if just take a moment and then
uh the the reality that like i lost like
i literally lost my dream
okay
and as i deeply unpack to theodore
roosevelt
next
lead us to the next one oh my goodness
wow okay oh yeah
okay i watch a lot of youtube on my
television and there's not
it's not like an intuitive like
subscribe thing you can't watch look at
comments you can't look at description
but youtube is serving me people that i
would watch a video on and then they're
serving me another one of their videos
sometimes i click on it and then they
serve me more of their videos because of
consumption that's why i feel like it is
properly rated in the sense that like if
you never subscribe to a person you will
get hit with them yeah you sat on their
video and you watched it through yeah
yeah and i think clicking subscribe when
i think about like my parents when i
think of my parents they don't subscribe
to like anyone maybe they have like
they've subscribed to like five channels
i'm subscribed to like 5 000 channels
right so the difference of even
demographically who you're going after i
think that a lot of people who are
getting started maybe in uh their legacy
years or they have been in a career and
they're starting to teach that career
they're hitting a demographic that it's
not intuitive for that to be a thing and
they're not watching it yet on their tvs
we're so deep that we're like of course
youtube on your tv you know and i think
that's one of the ones we have on our
list for the show is our subscribers
overrated or underrated i think
subscribers are overrated now they are
baseline potentially and you do want to
build them because the video goes out
and it's distributed but to your point
click-through rate and average view
duration is what matters
and
i'm watching videos on my smartphone uh
smart tv as well when you consume a
video your parents my parents now who
have youtubers that are watching
they're just waiting for the algorithm
to keep feeding them that same creator
right and so most unsubscribed channels
might be being fed your videos where
your actual subscribers may have just
tuned out they don't log into youtube
anymore and depending on how long you've
been on the platform
uh dated subscribers could actually be a
hindrance or subscribers can hurt your
channel if you've pivoted your niche or
your brand because now they're not
clicking on your videos killing it yeah
100 agree with you and i think the
underrated stat that's compared like
opposite of that is the average video
per viewer i think is the stat where how
many videos does a viewer watch on your
channel on average that's the stat i
care sure more about necessarily than
even just the overall subscriber mount
strong so good okay uh what about an
upload schedule what's your take on that
i think it's overrated just post videos
like if you need the schedule to keep
you consistent
awesome but i think when if you again
you start dwelling on like the time of
the day this that and the other dude
just post videos right like that's
i i exactly people go okay i have three
in the can yeah should i post all three
this week or should i spread them out
over three weeks or i know i'm gonna go
on vacation and i'm like i i don't know
just post them all like post as many
videos as you can when you can but then
if like if i don't i said i'm gonna do
every tuesday and i did three tuesdays
in a row but if i don't do the fourth
tuesday this is so pretty is every like
no i honestly probably no one's gonna
care as much as you think what you are
also looking for yesterday we were
talking about videos ten years old that
just grew the channel six thousand views
six subscribers 25
66 new subscribers on the asus monitor
video what does that tell me it tells me
that in a way it kind of doesn't matter
when the video is uploaded yeah it
matters that it keeps getting watched
and it matters about just building a
library that people can access on demand
so of course posted at like a smart time
of the day not in the weird middle of
the night when probably your
you know demographic location audience
is asleep but once that video takes off
life following the 7r framework it can
just keep working for you and you never
look back and think when did i upload
that like that's not what matters what
matters is it's getting real-time views
today yeah i think the only time it
matters to be honest with you is when
it's like a regular show like a live
show it's a show like i think about even
uploads that aren't gonna start live
like for example like i follow corridor
crew i know every saturday morning
they're dropping a cgi artist reacts and
i'm gonna go i'm gonna watch it almost
every saturday and i know our hot ones
comes out and i'm like oh i want to
watch that show like and that's at a
certain time that's that's honestly that
would matter and uh another thing too is
i watched this channel called amen and
back they're a lifestyle channel and
they missed like three weeks
and they just posted on the community
tab like hey we're just taking a break
and their community was so supportive of
it and they were like wow this is the
first time we've ever taken a break and
just thinking about like don't let your
upload schedule control your life like
take breaks like it's you know
this is youtube but this is not yeah
this is not everything and i want to
encourage two people to like don't do a
press release on your schedule that's
right before you've like actually done
it or you had like
a huge pet peeve like don't declare yeah
a lot of big things are coming on the
channel i have new videos coming out
soon soon in the next two years
like like don't say anything just do it
and and people won't even necessarily
even know they're not paying attention
they're like oh you do let me put that
on my calendar like we'll just let's
just put it out when it's out when like
the apple pie is ready then it's ready
it's ready it's delicious every tuesday
eight pm for the rest of my life right
now
yeah
we had someone ask they were like i'm
going on vacation go on vacation that's
great that's great but what if i don't
post then don't then don't
yeah it's great yeah it's not uh hard
and fast okay uh joe rogan podcast
youtube
uh wait spotify now i mean drop or
spotify but i mean prop i'm sorry joe
rogan underrated uh clips on youtube
underrated or properly rated that's the
model we were sleeping on it yeah i mean
i think that that's the model is the
power of starting a video podcast is
number one you can put it on youtube and
spotify and everywhere else and it can
be search based on youtube and it can be
long form and build that depth but then
number two is that out of that podcast
if you're talking about topical moments
and talk topical ideas which he does so
he's consistently creating content in
the video podcast to the show point
talking about what just happened in news
and people care about his opinion so
it's headline after headline after
headline on the clip show that gives you
massive opportunity for exposure so
start a 20-minute video podcast and cut
two to three clips out of it and even
upload them on the same channel or use
them for micro content that's the model
yeah i think the model is definitely
underrated i think him i would just say
personally i think his opinion is
overrated people were like oh he's like
joe rose broken saying like
but you're right i think it's underrated
one thing i do like about it is when we
do our podcast we're sitting like um
side by side it's it's definitely more
high on the higher produced side we've
got nice gear joe rogan's like sitting
in a t-shirt they're not even the camera
is uh like a fly on the wall
feeling and i think that's actually
underrated the idea that it doesn't have
to feel overly produced like just turn
the camera on we were just talking to
ray edwards in the ultimate uh group and
you're like you're already doing the
podcast just flip a camera on and i feel
i feel a little tension on that one
because again joe rogan's 10 years into
this comedy career
some people see that and they want to
imitate what he's doing now at their
beginning and so when you're just having
conversations casually and you're not
getting to the point you have two to
three hour conversations and you're not
getting kanye west right on your show
elon musk elon musk then then
then you might want to be brief be
bright be fun and be done until people
would actually care to listen to longer
kind of chill relaxed talking about fear
factor it's like that was such like a
quick pace show it was like you that's
where his influence really and so it is
a cool model but i think it'd be a tough
model to grow if nobody knows you unless
you just unpack and and if it takes a
ton of time to get to the wisdom like or
what it even is like i don't know it'd
be tough yeah we don't go into our shows
just uh what are we going to talk about
today like with some headlights we are
like structuring shows
thinking about the topic thinking about
where does this fit in the content
structure like we're we're still
planning a ton where i think that after
you've built influence you can't just
come and sit on a couch and just start
talking about what it's worth like i
think we have some influence but i'm
actually operating as if we have none
yeah i'm i'm assuming people don't know
us i'm assuming we haven't started i'm
assuming nobody knows our podcast yet
i'm assuming we don't have trust we are
not joe rogan um and i hope for what
it's worth i hope that like you kind of
have that always beginner mentality a to
maybe stay anchored in humility but b to
say
maybe i hope in fact i'm really vibing
on this like i actually like this should
be like a show i know religion and maybe
we're ready now yeah but we weren't two
years ago six years into this yeah yeah
and like maybe this could come out now
and people will be interested let us
know like we put this you know a show
conversations like this um but how do we
get here
you know search-based titles like
delivering value like pre-planning it
like really putting in the work so that
hopefully you would even be at this
event growth video live let us know
but shout out to sean for i think
sean grew so much as an interviewer he
he grew in a way that he knew what he
was pulling he wanted to pull out of
people i think some people start
podcasts and they you think people care
about what you think but then you got
guests on your show and then you're like
still talking over your guests but
you're not growing as an interviewer and
i think uh you know that's one way like
video influencers was grown was sean
knew he was who is interviewing he
pre-planned the questions in advance
came up with the hook because of that
but just like he controlled the
interview but allowed the person to
share i think there's there's there's
wisdom in that i think joe rogan knew
that
you know over time he'd become joe rogan
the podcast but he was so good at having
a conversation yeah and facilitating he
is he is and he goes there he knows he
unpacks things he creates an environment
there's nuances all right pull one from
there i'm gonna ask some off-topic ones
because i need your opinion on this
green juice
underrated
okay i mean health benefits we were just
talking here though about uber greens
and everyone like john nacarado was like
i'm just going to finish this this is
awful and cami was like what is in this
is this the green
is this the green chard and i go i drink
that every day candy
that's my favorite beverage yeah
i feel like i think of green juice the
same way i think about cleanses i feel
like they're overrated but again i'm not
you know it's funny it's like it's
a big body i'm healthy after a
cleansing your body a lot of green juice
has got 55 grams of sugar in them they
do oh yeah so you love those ones
you would love those but like that's
that's the last one last one think media
think media is underrated bro nobody
knows who think he is i think we're just
getting started man i think that i think
we we still have a lot to learn i think
we're still for sure we have a forget a
forever beginner mentality a forever
student mentality and i think that'll
help us continue to win but i yeah i
mean and i mean like what's kind of
crazy is this feels this year is crazy
this year's grow a video
um but i was even just talking to john
like
we haven't even had omar doing two a
week nolan doing two a week for very
long we haven't been in this era for
very long the think media podcast is not
that old you're a youtube made simple
show just got a logo coffee with kennel
show got a logo last week
i mean we're still like you know just
trying to build and and um and so i
think about just different people
whoever you look up to or whatever a lot
of times when people really build
something
you're you're discovering them like
you're 15 or year 20 or year 10 and
think media is about five years old and
then my journey was about five years
before that and so you know what what's
five years from now look like i don't
even know that's gonna be crazy kind of
crazy i i say underrated in the sense
number one because of our positioning
but i would also say like the channel
itself is underrated because a lot of
people find us because they had a
problem and then maybe maybe they
subscribe but uh oftentimes i get the
question you know
a question on my dms or somewhere else
and we have a video on that and i think
not too many people know how much
is on think media and that you can use
this as an archive as a library of
videos search in the thing but i think
that underrates us because not too many
people built a library of a youtube
channel so that you could serve a people
more than just one video and i would say
too like we're underrated in the sense
of like people who consume a lot of
content but don't actually
post they they consume more than they
create might even look at us go oh
you're overrated but it's yeah because
you just consume everything sure you
just literally consume everything all
these different voices you're not
actually creating i think for actual
creators like they like we're still even
underrated for those people it's just
like we are people that like prioritize
action constant learner like you said
beginner mentality and i think that we
just are just getting started on what
we're going to do we have so many dreams
of things we want to get into so yeah we
have big things coming someone said you
guys are like think university yes a
free university who would have thought
right um all right thank you guys so
much that was awesome
i feel i i feel a show in the future for
sure because that was a super fun one
well that was a ton of fun and i'm so
excited we got to bring that episode to
you if you're watching on youtube right
now actually let us know what are your
takes on the things that we talked about
the different topics that were discussed
during that episode i'd love to know if
you think it's overrated or underrated
and that was a session from grow with
video live and i am excited to tell you
that we have locked the dates for growth
video live
2022 and yes it's gonna be in person
this year in las vegas so if you want
more information about growth video live
2022 happening in may you can go to
growethvideolive.com
right now to get all the details and the
best pricing for this conference well i
want to thank you for those who have
left a review on our podcast over on
apple it means so much to us to be able
to read these reviews and get to hear
from you and get to see how this podcast
is actually impacting your youtube
channels and your businesses and today's
podcast reading comes from or podcast
review comes from athena she says
by following the tips shared on this
podcast i've improved my skills and have
grown my youtube channel six times
faster than ever before oh my goodness
athena six times faster that is amazing
thank you so much for being a part of
the think media community and for being
someone who will was willing to leave a
review and let us know how this podcast
is helping you if you want to share this
podcast with a friend all you have to do
right now is take a screenshot on your
phone share it on social media and tag
us at official think media and i'd love
to be able to reshare that
with our community well that's all for
today's episode and we'll catch you in
the next one bye
you